it takes a big jump oh
this was a white napkin when I started
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Brian Cranston
he's a six-time Emmy award-winning actor
you know from Acclaim Broadway
performances films that include 2013's
best picture Argo and iconic TV shows
like Malcolm in the Middle and Breaking
Bad he also stars in the crime drama
your honor which returns for its much
anticipated second season on Showtime
January 15th and I for one can't wait
Brian Cranston welcome back to the show
oh Sean I'm already regretting this
what's going through your head is he
prepare to take on this Gauntlet for a
second when I did this before it was
like eight years ago
when I was promoting why him and I
thought when I left I thought that was
the most bizarre interview I've ever
done this won't last
it's a gimmick no one no celebrity in
their right mind is gonna do what I just
oh my gosh how many years you've been
doing this now since then so yeah like
eight years believe it or not
and they said you want to go on hot ones
again I go yeah
wait a minute what was hot ones
um but I'm I'm up I'm off the task yeah
I'm I'm up I'm not familiar with any of
these hot sauces so you'll have to
you'll have to introduce them to me as
we go along well it'll be an education
are you ready to get started yeah
[Music]
now your eyes are already starting to
water well I'm just I'm just happy and
proud to see you again it's more
sentimentality than anything okay
well this one is um tasty but not not
that hot enjoy that while you can
okay
[Music]
so there's some basic similarities
between Michael your character and your
honor and Walter White and the sense of
having a good character who makes some
dark choices in an effort to protect
their family what fascinates you about
the life forces that can push an
otherwise upstanding member of society
towards a dark and morally compromised
path
well from an acting standpoint they're
the most fun to play
when you have characters that are
damaged to a certain point complex
conflicted
flawed
but I think what is the key to getting
an audience behind you on this is that
they see that there's something else
trying to get out trying to be better
trying to improve and as long as an
audience sees that someone isn't just
relishing being bad
they'll root for you you know
[Music]
jaquanda's Banshee Ranch oh
tasty
so in a Fresh Air interview on the heels
of your Tony award-winning performances
LBJ and all the way you tell a
fascinating little detail about the
vocal strain and physical toll of doing
an eight show per week Broadway schedule
what are silent Mondays and why have
they served as a secret weapon for you
there's a beautiful and talented actor
named Audra McDonald
um and she is not only a great actor but
a terrific singer
and she was doing Porgy and Bess at the
time I was about to come in with all the
way which is a three-hour play and I can
already start to feel the strain on my
vocal cords and I thought oh my God I'm
about to do six months on Broadway I
need help how did you do Porgy and Bess
and she told me that she went I think to
her ear nose and throat doctor and he
wrote a prescription for her and and the
prescription was for silence no laughing
no Whispering no utterance of any kind
completely shut down the vocal cords
and I thought you know what I'm gonna do
that
so at first it was odd but I kept a pad
around and my wife was I go you know
hungry lunch and I go out and I go to a
restaurant what's the soup you know and
pretty soon I started to keep some of
these where's my soup sign here it is
you know it's like what's the soup and
people would would go
they didn't get it that I and I I wrote
one I'm on vocal rest right and then in
in response to that they go oh
okay and I had another one you don't
have to whisper
[Music]
that's a nasty looking thing yeah it's
like a mythical sort of like dog wolf
and then when it would attack its eyes
turn red
will that happen to us when we eat at
sauce we'll see if it's an attack mode I
should do a little special effects right
now
okay
so while reading your Memoir of life in
Parts I was really captured by the
romantic way that you talk about
baseball and being inspired by the way
Wally Moon would swing for the left
field fences when the LA Dodgers played
in the LA Coliseum do you have an
all-time favorite Vin scully-ism well I
thought I did in 81 when he talked about
if you have a sombrero throw it to the
sky
um when Fernando Valenzuela pitched a
no-hitter
but then in 88
Kirk Gibson hits his home run
you know and he says in a season filled
with unproppable the The Impossible has
happened
still feel like I'm in mourning for him
passing because I've been listening to
him for 60 years and Vin Scully
represented to me just more than
baseball to me
it was a sanctuary
when I had a rough childhood I can
always tune out put on my transistor put
in my earphones and listen to him take
me away and at least for those three
hours I felt like I was gonna be okay
everything's safe
nothing to worry about and I would just
listen to his mellifluous voice and he
would tell stories and I would just go
off and I get a baseball game I hear I
just it's just it just felt like
floating sometimes
[Music]
okay
going in yeah
[Music]
all right so far so good there we go
what did you mean when you said that an
actor approaching a comedic scene can't
for one second think what they're doing
is funny
if you're doing a sketch like if you're
doing Saturday Night Live part of the
fun from the audience perspective is
they're having fun knowing you're having
fun right and so you're kind of in on it
we all laugh when someone breaks
character and starts cracking up and
they're trying to look away we get even
more enjoyment out of it and that's
legitimate it's fun it's loose it's life
but if you're doing a film or television
show that's carefully scripted if the
character realizes something's funny it
it takes the onus off the audience to
laugh because they're doing it you're
doing it it's the same thing when a
character easily cries if a character
cries easily the audience doesn't have
to but if a character tries not to cry
that's when the audience will
a little bit of curryish
so far
we're five in five to go halfway point
yep
I gotta say
tasty
but not crushing not like oh my God I
can't do this anymore see I told you
there's no you should there should have
been no nervousness about coming back
you know no anxiety about coming back
you got this well this is only half time
we got the whole second half well I'll
do into a false sense of security thing
in the front half yeah
so we talked to actors in the past about
picking and sequencing roles but you're
the first one I've ever come across that
has a full-blown project assessment
scale where you break down everything
from story to script role director and
cast of all the scripts that have come
across your desk what percentage would
you say fail the writing test and then
how early can you tell
so the one I mentioned before that
didn't have a high scale on the on the
writing was why him
uh why him had a very simple premise
Midwestern dad doesn't like the
boyfriend of his his you know cherished
daughter
that's it
and I
didn't anyway I taught I talk to my
publicist and I said
is it possible that I can get a hold of
Paul Rudd so I called Paul and I said
Paul you worked on these movies before
the script seems just kind of there
there's some funny situations and jokes
but it doesn't like wow
and he goes that's kind of the nature of
this kind of movie it relies heavily on
the on the ensemble cast to be able to
punch it up
and just play so we will do scenes we
will shoot the scene as it's written and
then then you go then you're adding
lines then you're how about this and
then someone says something you add to
Anta then pretty soon you're like
and it becomes something completely
different and you can't script that
several improvisations that I came up
with ended up in the film and it was
like oh man this is this is so much fun
and so I learned my lesson from that it
was a good lesson that that scale that I
usually go by is not always accurate
foreign
we had Margot Robbie on the show she
talked about how working in soaps was a
really great and valuable education for
an actor because it taught you how to
work fast and be Word Perfect does that
resonate with you yeah fast you got to
work fast and there's a pattern in
daytime television I don't even know if
the medium really even works anymore but
the pattern in daytime was people are
watching a few times a week but not
every day like two or two and a half
times a week or something is the average
so if I said Sean I saw you with Margo
the other day and you're trying to get
Catelyn away from me
I will kill you you know and then then
the next day I might say remember Sean
when I warned you and when you talk to
Margot that if you got in the way of God
and I would kill you there's it's so
similar it's so similar that your brain
said no you just said this and you're
going oh my God I just said this I'm
repeating it and you just go through I
learned just plow through
because at first I would stop and go oh
sorry I I'm repeating aren't I and they
go no that's the line I'm so sorry now
I'm more sorry so now I just learned
just go through and then go was that
right was that yeah it was right okay
and you move on
now we're getting psyched yeah angry
goat dreams of calypso okay
that's an interest ing taste
it smells like calypso
yeah I can sense that coming down the
line
so I know that herbal tobacco is often
used as a marijuana substitute in TV and
film do you have any insight into what
goes into making like TV math like what
is TV math
TV methamphetamine the way we made it
with a little blue tint
is actually rock candy
and it and the flavor was cotton candy
rock candy
I never tasted it until one night
we were working it was probably the 16th
or 17th hour we're working in the in our
dungeon downstairs our our lab down
there
and Gus Fring is making sure we're
working and we're working and I see
Aaron Paul reach into our product our
handful of our product starts throwing
throwing the methamphetamine in his
mouth I go what are you doing you can't
eat the product he goes I'm getting so
tired I mean it's like you're really
getting a high off this inside well it's
sugar and he goes you've tasted it I go
no I haven't tasted that he goes oh you
should taste it I go no I don't think so
he goes and I guess I was still in
character because Walter White wouldn't
right it's not I'm not doing it and he
goes take you gotta have one
yo I have one what he would say and so
all right all right you know to shut you
up and I tasted one it was like
foreign
that's pretty good and so he and I they
took they rolled the camera and he and I
are just talking we're like eating all
the all the methamphetamine
um and that's what we use we use uh
cotton candy rock candy
[Music]
it's that bomb Beyond insanity
whoa
[Music]
do most people just take one bite
especially when we get here yeah here it
comes yeah
hello Mama yeah
wow the bomb Beyond it so what you're
saying as I wipe my brows yeah careful
around your eyes too yeah
is that this is not the hottest one
so here's where
this might be good news this might be
good news this one is the hottest one oh
you know like uh I'm gonna switch things
up
we start by like the Scoville scale
which is a measure of capsization per
unit there go the hiccups
and this one actually falls here
but there's something about it that's
crazy you know like remember when we did
this like seven eight seven eight years
ago
this was still here it's the only bottle
that stayed on the table that whole time
yeah that one's kick ass uh-huh
so back in 2019 you and your Breaking
Bad co-star Aaron Paul launched dos
Hombres what distinguishes like a good
Mezcal from the kind that you're exposed
to early on during like your poker
playing days
um
okay
so the difference
is recipe just like anything
I could put in front of you
all the ingredients to make the perfect
dinner
but if you're not a chef you don't know
how what goes with what and how to put
it together it's the same thing with
spirits
how long do you smoke it how long do you
ferment it how many times you filter it
I mean you know I mean there's a lot
going on
you look like you're in substantial pain
way worse than you way worse than you I
have to say you know
I'm so like amazed at how well you took
that was that was a that was a kick-ass
one yeah it's still it's still kicking
but the way that you were able to just
kind of internalize it deliver an
eloquent interview answer and then look
me up and down and be like hey buddy
what's going on with you
yes that's true I'm impressed
the interesting thing is is is the
perspiration yeah that's what always
fascinating I can understand the power
of the of the peppers doing their thing
in your mouth
what's with the perspiration
[Music]
whoa
that one is the hottest oh this was a
white napkin when I started
[Music]
wow
so this next one
is the butterfly Bakery Taco Vibes only
Taco Vibes only
all right
now this one
hot but
after the last one
[Music]
kind of a walk in the park that's so far
look at you
when you think about the odd jobs that
you had before your breakthrough in
Hollywood is there one that you'd say
was most Paramount or helpful in your
acting career like I've heard you talk
about when you worked at the dating
matchmaking service greater expectations
or Great Expectations that it was almost
like taking an acting class Great
Expectations
um great company very successful company
it was the precursor to match.com and
all those things
um
and you'd go in and uh depending on your
proclivity you you look at the men's or
the women's and you're looking and you
go she smokes I don't want to be with
smoker and then oh she's close
she's oh we went to the same school we
love basketball oh this looks like a
nice person and then you'd go to see her
tape and that's where I come in because
I did the the videotape interviews I
would sit across from someone and I had
a a camera here
but I would never turn it on until I
felt that that person's Essence was real
oh and alive
and then at some point they really did
relax
calm down and they laugh and usually
when they laughed at something I'd start
it so the first thing that the person
watching their tape would see them
laughing which is the most
engaging thing you can see someone
letting go and they laugh and then
they're talking and we'd talk for a
minute and a half not long I turn it off
I go good we're done
I go what wait but I didn't get out uh
you know that I like to do this and I go
that's not about that
this is about them seeing you as you are
most of the time
that's what they want to see how is this
person going to act when I'm sitting
across with them drinking coffee
and it was unbelievably successful it
was really good well I can see why with
employees like that all right all right
Brian Cranston oh what's happening
okay here we go put a last dab
okay there you go
last step last dab will do you we're
through look at that we did it again we
survived at us who would have thought
okay here it goes cheers
[Music]
so to close things out if you would I'd
love for you to unpackage this quote of
yours the homework doesn't guarantee
anything with luck it gives you a shot
at something real
I often get asked by Young acting
students in high school and college
how do you do it where how can I uh you
know Libra and I go shortcut
yeah yeah yeah how are you
like a drug ah give me the shortcake
there's no shortcut sorry
yeah
the sweating thing is surprising
uh
but that's that's what
um that's what a a real love of acting
is is is
it's it's a relationship
it's not a flame it is committing to
something for the rest of your life
when I think of acting and I think of
creating and writing I mean it it
occupies all of me and I love it
if I ever start to complain about having
to go to work at six o'clock in the
morning
or not wanting to do anything I don't
want to do that
then that's the sign I've I've lost
the flame and it's time to hang it up
Mike drop and look at you Brian Cranston
for the second time taking on the hot
ones Gauntlet and living to tell the
tale now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
um well second season of of your honor
I'm very proud of it it's on Showtime
first season ended in tragedy now we're
exploring the world of grief
and and forgiveness is that is that
still are we still able to have that in
our society and some people will think
that asking forgiveness or granting for
forgiveness
is a weakness
I think it's a human strength it's a
human strength it'll allow you to be
with other people especially with a an
intimate partner if you can't say you're
sorry you will never be in a long-term
relationship
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's the hot ones experience
experience
did it again I'll see who who would like
would you like some more
I have eight I have nine
hot ones fans exciting news the season
20 hot ones 10 pack is now available if
you've ever watched from home and
wondered to yourself how hard are the
wings really or been one of those people
that's like oh they're only taking one
bite well you know what if you think you
could do better now is the time to put
your money where your mouth is literally
with the hot ones season 20 10 pack
available exclusively at heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 20 hot ones 10 pack
get them while they're high
[Music]
[Applause]